renaud girard c'est business as usual
parce que c'est pas le premier tir de
missile nord-coréen ou bien est-ce qu'on
a franchi un degré supplémentaire dans
la dans la tension
oui on a franchi un degré supplémentaire
parce que ce qui est important c'est que
kim jong-un donc le jeune dictateur
rocketman rocket man down en pièces un
caddie nasty je suis découvert la corée
du nord depuis
après la deuxième guerre mondiale donc
le petit fils a dit que la corée du nord
est est un état nucléaire capables de
parler d'égal à égal avec les états unis
puisqu'il savait cette dissuasion
intercontinental qui pouvait donc
projeté des missiles jusqu'au territoire
américain
mais comme la speakerine l'a bien dit
que c'était en fait pour servir la
stabilité et la paix dans le monde et
n'a pas assorti cette fierté d'avoir
l'armé nucléaire de menace pour
quiconque dans la région mais dit
effectivement quiconque attaquera les
intérêts de la colère donc c'est une
assurance vie je pense qu'à prix
kim jong-un est ce que je crois que
donald trump va faire quelque chose non
je crois que donald trump est un faux
dur je crois qu'il parle beaucoup il
fait peu a fondu ou un faux dur c'est
les gens qui agissent souvent parle très
peu et agissent lui il parle beaucoup il
twin beaucoup mais il agir assez peu
assez peu contre la chine la chine a pas
beaucoup avancer c'est ses positions en
mer de chu de chine méridionale sur les
petites îles au spart les et paracels et
c'est très bien fait pl je pense je
pense qu'il ne fera strictement rien il
ne peut rien faire et donc c'est c'est
aujourd'hui nous fêtons un échec
stratosphérique de la stratégie
américaine depuis depuis 20 ans ils se
sont attaqués ils ont dépensé 1500
milliards de dollars en 2003 pour contre
un pays pour détruire disait-il des
armes de destruction massive qui
n'existait pas en irak mais ils ont
laissé se développer au même
ces armes de la question basque ivan
cori et qui existent bel et bien et je
vois pas ce qu'il pourrait faire